when i watch your interviews with people
who
most of the time aren't physicists they
seem to be resistant
on that space time is emergent like
michael schermer
and he was saying well you probably
talked to the minority of physicists
that think that
space time is immersion that's not in
fact true
most physicists as far as i know
actually believe that space time is
emergent
nema is one of them lee smallin
so why do you think that there's this
aversion
to modest that is monoism
theory is predicated on the primacy of
consciousness rather than the primacy
being material
why is it that that's the sticking point
right well and even among physicists
who recognize that space time isn't
fundamental
you won't find very many of them
arguing that therefore consciousness is
a good candidate for what is
you fundamental i've been to an fqxi um
meeting of physicists where they were
looking at the role of the observer in
physics at banff
a few years ago and
even in that context where where they
were looking at the role of the observer
in physics i didn't see any of the
physicists there interested in taking
consciousness
as fundamental and and i think
the attitude is why
take such a huge leap i mean
letting go of space time is one thing
but jumping into consciousness i mean
that that
for i think most physicists would say
that's a much bigger leap than we need
to take let's try to find
just some deeper structure beyond space
time and for example this is i think
the brilliant work that nima or kanye
hamed is doing where he's saying
look we can look
at these so-called positive geometries
behind space-time the amplitude
a sociohedron and and other things that
he's finding
positive grasmanians the bigger
structure that includes many of these
and and he doesn't know what that realm
is about
which is fine but he's finding the
mathematical structure so he's finding
that there are these symmetries like in
the amplitude
um that can't be captured
in space-time they also have found that
the mathematical
description of the scattering amplitudes
the computations of the scattering
amplitudes
um become much much simpler when you let
go of space time if you use
feynman diagrams and have virtual
particles in space time then you could
have hundreds or thousands of pages
but in this deeper space that he's
finding this pure math
um it collapses to a few terms that you
can compute by hand
and so so i think that the physicists
are saying let's you know let's not
jump further than we have to let's if we
have to let go of space time let's just
find
some let's let's let the mathematics
guide us first
um and we can try things like well let's
just try like quantum bits in quantum
case
seth lloyd i think at mit took a a an
approach
and quantum what quantum bits and
quantum gates
gates right okay right so your space
time isn't fundamental let's
let's pause it something that's not
conscious just quantum bits and quantum
gates
and what what seth lloyd was able to
show is that you could
in some sense get little patches of
space-time
general relativistic space time where
the curvature of this little patch was
proportional to the
action of the gate and so instead of
starting with space times fundamental
you start with quantum bits and quantum
gates
um where those bits and gates come from
again that's now that's that's your new
assumption it's not space-time it's just
bits and gates and you can ask
you know who ordered that why should the
universe be fundamentally that
now so the reason why i go there
even though i think most physicists
don't is that
as a cognitive neuroscientist i'm very
interested
in the problem was called the heart
problem of consciousness
right we have lots of correlations
between brain activity
and conscious experiences like i like to
use the example of area v4
of cortex left hemispheres back over
here somewhere
if you take a magnet and just touch it
to your skull there
a transcranial magnetic stimulator and
inhibit before
you will lose all color experiences in
the right visual field everything to the
right of where you're looking
you will lose color experiences you turn
off the magnet color experiences come
back
and we have dozens maybe hundreds of
correlations like that between specific
kinds of neural activity
and specific conscious experiences but
we have no scientific theories
that can explain um that correlation
there are none
um for any specific there's not a
scientific theory that can explain even
one specific
conscious experience like the taste of
chocolate or the smell of garlic that
says for example this pattern of brain
activity
or this functional aspect of brain
activity um
must be the taste of chocolate it
couldn't be the the smell of
um you know a rose and these are the
precise reasons why
there's just nothing on the table and so
i'm trying to
[Music]
solve two problems i'm trying to say the
reason why space time is
not fundamental is because something
else is
consciousness and if i start with
consciousness i can perhaps get a theory
that explains
this correlation between conscious
experiences and brain states but i don't
start with
something in space-time namely brain
states i don't start with brain states
and and figure out how they cause
consciousness i go the other way around
to start with consciousness and show how
it
creates space time as a data structure
and
brains and neurons as particular um
objects within that data structure
so so the idea of the big picture idea
is
if space time isn't fundamental as the
physicists are now recognizing
then objects in space time
and just so people are clear this is not
as this is not new that space time isn't
fundamental it's not like a kooky theory
this has been going around since the 80s
just so that they don't think you're
glamming on to some fad
that that that's right and yeah you know
i think as you said most physicists now
most you know first-rank theoretical
physicists just recognize that it's sort
of just
of course space-time isn't fundamental
and of course our job is to try to
figure out what's the next step